To all citizens of the dominion,
on this eve of my last birthday
as your queen,
let us have one last
festivity together.
Let's party.
Vampire Academy is about
the friendship
between two young women,
Rose and Lissa.
As they enter the adult world,
they realize
the differences between them
in class might be the thing
that either tears them apart
or makes them
change the world together.
Have you ever met a
royal Moroi,
in a high position of power, with a Dhampir best friend?
In this dominion, there are
three distinct classes.
The Moroi, a benevolent,
mortal vampire.
The Dhampir are raised to serve the Moroi
as Guardians.
They protect them against
the Strigoi.
Immortal, blood-thirsty vampires.
Rose Hathaway is a Dhampir.
She wants to be the best guardian.
Yet she questions,
"Why am I doing this?"
I want to protect my
best friend,
and I want a life to call my own.
Lissa Dragomir is a royal
Moroi vampire.
She starts off the story
really naive.
Her life kind of gets flipped
upside down.
For the next heir to the throne,
I name Vasilissa Dragomir.
It's all very juicy and
very dramatic.
I like young love.
I like love triangles.
I like the star-crossed lovers.
There's Lissa and Christian.
He's a royal Moroi.
Unfortunately, he is
an outcast.
I heard you spend a lot
of time here.
Books don't gossip about me.
They sort of have this spark.
There's a real love there and
a real genuine connection.
We shouldn't do this.
Absolutely not.
I like the love that was
not meant to be.
I like the love that
tears us apart.
And Rose and Dimitri
embody all of that.
Dimitri is an expert guardian.
Their chemistry is real.
You need this fight, Rose.
I know you're hurting
and I'd do anything
to make it stop.
One of the great things about
this show is that
we have all these
amazing fights.
The stunt team created
something beautiful.
It's like a dance.
You'll see a lot of
precision and skill.
They're everything I think everyone wants to see
when you're fighting vampires.
It's pretty cool
getting to do all of the training
and the fighting,
and it's just nice to see
black girls kicking ass,
and being brave and
being beautiful.
And I live for that.
I live for that.
We deserve a better future.
Moroi and Dhampir alike.
Vampire Academy has something
very profound to say
about equality.
Gotten across in a fun and
entertaining way.
Vampire Academy has love
and romance.
It's got royal yumminess.
It tells stories of loss and grief,
but it is also the origin story
of a revolution.
If this is the way the world is,
then maybe it's the world that
needs to change.
And what a thrill to be able
to tell that kind of story
with two young women
at the center.
We are all apart of this dominion.